why do I suddenly have a desperate need
for Krispy Kreme Doughnuts in that a
coincidence even has the Power Rangers
on the Box Power Rangers is the latest
thing that was once a thing that's kind
of still a thing that's a thing again
this big-screen adaptation of the 90s
Mighty Morphin Power Ranger saga
features five young teenagers who are
going through a lot of problems in their
life who find these five magical rocks
and these rocks give them superpowers
and they eventually learned that they
have to team up to become the Power
Rangers to fight against the evil Rita
Repulsa who's going to destroy I guess
this little town that they're in and
then I guess eventually probably the
world after that I would assume
otherwise it's just a small town so I
mean mistakes are really I guess they're
not as high as some films if you guys
saw my hilarious T review of the Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers movie from 95 then
you know I grew up with this show but
I'm not horrific Alena static about it I
have warm feelings of fuzziness I have
the entire show on DVD because sometimes
it's just enjoyable to watch it's
incredibly cheesy and it knows it which
is what I always liked about the Power
Rangers show in the 90s it knew what it
was it never tried to be too serious it
was just a lot of fun this Power Rangers
movie is definitely going in a more
gritty aspect I wouldn't really say it's
dark but it definitely goes for more of
a realistic sense especially with the
kids in their lives and what they're
dealing with in fact one of my favorite
scenes in the movie is a campfire
sequence where they all have a
heart-to-heart with one another and they
connect and that's what I really enjoyed
about this movie was the connection that
they all shared the sense of teamwork
and surprisingly all five of them have
really good chemistry and even more
surprisingly there are actually really
good actors they do a really good job in
this film especially the Blue Ranger he
was probably my favorite he was in
danger of becoming annoying and some of
the early scenes but that quickly faded
into the background and became kind of
endearing I really liked all of them
actually they were well fleshed out if
you are hardcore rain
I feel like this movie will probably
give you what you need if you go to this
movie expecting a film not so much the
Power Rangers movie has a lot of
storytelling flaws and some really
hilariously over-the-top things that
don't really match for one I like
Elizabeth Banks a lot and what she's
doing with Rita Repulsa is basically
exactly what a talented actor would
probably do if they wanted to recreate
the source material because if you go
back to the 90s and look at Rita Repulsa
in that show you get this guy making
money by golly just like Queens
totally dumb doubt it make you yours and
Friends and that's basically what she's
doing in this movie that's very
over-the-top hilariously cheesy
performance that I actually kind of
enjoyed on that level but unfortunately
the other actors in the movie are
actually doing a pretty good job at
being serious and these two tones they
just don't mix the problem I think is is
that whoever was making this movie and
calling the shots and the major
decisions whether it was the studio or
really was a director and writer for
once on one of these big-budget movies
they didn't commit to one of them if
they wanted to go the cheesy route they
should have just gone to it 100% if they
wanted to go to gritty routes they
should have just gone to it 100% but
they have a mix of both and it causes a
lot of conflicting emotions the action
sequences are fine they were actually
kind of disappointing to me there's
quite a bit of slow fast mo that's 300
Michael Bay style of directing action
that just didn't really look as cool as
I think they wanted it to there really
isn't that much of the Power Rangers in
their suits kicking ass and the stuff
with the Zord towards the end I really
didn't buy actually to tell the truth
leading up to the big climactic action
scene I thought the movie was okay it's
actually once they got their suits on
that I thought the movie kind of tanked
and went downhill because the stuff they
do is so over the top and it just
doesn't mix you have a serious setup of
an origin story that follows a lot of
the origin story cliches that we've
to expect and in the same time you have
read a repulsive creating a monster out
of gold and going oh I'm like doing
crazy weird things like that this isn't
a spoiler because it's been basically
every trailer and there's even posters
of this but when they get in there
various ships and vehicles they're
piloting them perfectly as if they've
done it for years now they show our
characters training in fighting styles
and learning how to fight against the
fake putty man that they use as sparring
partners but they've never piloted these
vehicles before and for a second there's
a shot where something connects to one
of their back so I was like oh they're
doing it through their mind that's why
they're able to do this perfectly and
the pink Ranger can fly a jet but later
in the same scene that blue Ranger is
like I don't know how to do that these
pressing buttons trying to figure out
how to do a cert maneuver so no they are
controlling these things I just don't
really buy it how are they flying jets
how are they controlling these high-tech
vehicles without destroying an entire
town and killing a billion people but
the setup for the characters and them as
a team is actually pretty strong
surprisingly better than I thought it
would be Bryan Cranston has a floating
head Zordon is really good interestingly
he voiced some of the characters in the
original Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
which is why Billy Cranston's character
was named Cranston and here he is in the
movie playing Zordon that's kind of
interesting
Bill Hader is alpha 5 I always found
alpha 5 annoying a in the show and
I found them pretty much annoying in
this movie too so if you like alpha 5
the way he is in the show you'll
probably like alpha 5 I don't I'm not
really a fan of that character at all to
be honest I actually kind of enjoyed the
movie until they got their suits which I
feel like I'll probably be in the
minority there since everybody wants to
see them in their armor kicking ass but
to me the film kind of departed from
what it was it was a semi realistic
movie until Rita Repulsa is creating
things out of gold and all of a sudden
there's giant battles between a Megazord
and this Goldar creature and it is like
this kind of lost me all of a sudden
our kid a week now you guys are probably
wondering why in the hell are there
Krispy Kreme Doughnuts by me well that's
because Krispy Kreme plays a major
character in this film I mean I have
never seen so much Krispy Kreme in my
life this is like the most product
placement I've ever seen in a movie
maybe this was a serious Krispy Kreme
bank that this movie made oh my god like
I can't even actually explain it because
it's kind of a spoiler
that's how integral Krispy Kreme is to
this movie I think hardcore fans of
Power Rangers will probably get their
money's worth here it did remind me of a
Transformers movie sometimes there's
even a transformers joke and whenever a
movie opens with a joke about jacking
off a cow it has me worried grateful
there's not that much of that but
for a while I was like oh no this is
going to be transformers five isn't it
just with Power Rangers gratefully they
do actually try the characters in the
movie are fairly fleshed out more
fleshed out than I thought they were
going to be to where I can actually get
behind them a little bit but once they
get their suits it just kind of got
really silly and Rita Repulsa is also
extremely silly and I think the Power
Rangers are silly but the set up was a
lot more grounded so it was kind of a
departure from everything that happened
before that but still if you're not
really that worried about watching a
film in theaters and you just want to
see the Power Rangers kick some ass I
think we'll probably enjoyed this movie
I'm going to give Power Rangers a C+
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to my review of
life as well as my robe one analysis
I've been working on since December I'm
going to post that this weekend you guys
are the best thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]
you